Being a nerd is hard work, you
guys.
Uh, but don't ask me.
I'm a fake geek girl.
Now, there's a ton of comics.
There's...
That's so true. That's funny.
There's comics to read,
there's games to play,
there's so many movies to watch,
people with bad opinions online
to argue with,
and now, suits to buy!
OppoSuits just introduced
the PAC-MAN suit.
Now, a lot of people tweeted me
this suit right here.
Which, um, I really have
to point out now--
this legit looks like a suit
people would wear to my funeral.
-Uh...
-(laughter)
Now, I knew this would be
remarkably on brand for me,
but as a 44-year-old man
who's about to get married,
I think maybe,
maybe a head-to-to PAC-MAN suit
is just a little much at this
point in my life, all right?
Maybe I'm not gonna do that.
Why, yes, I actually did buy
the Pac-Man suit after all.
Um, I'm sorry
if it's hard to hear me
over your screaming genitalia
right now.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this arcade is closed!
-Uh... I...
-(laughter)
I know what I said before
in the opening of the show,
but the truth of the matter is,
I bought this (bleep) thing
the second
it became available...
and here it is,
and it's amazing.